hello and welcome back to New rockstars
I'm Jessica Clemens and we know blade is
coming back to the MCU and I'm so dang
stoked on it so much so that I've
decided to re-watch my first blade movie
that dropped in 1998 and guess what it's
still great it still holds up some of
y'all could have been well into
adulthood at the time or graduating
middle school or not even been born so
please let me show you all the things
I've spotted that stood out to me as
things that can and should be moved from
the original 1998 movie Blade to our
newer one that's coming in 2024. I'll
break down if you will thank you to
Marvel snap for sponsoring this video
more on them in a moment while the 1998
blade originates from Earth 26320 the
new blade should take place on Earth
616. so the characters in the storyline
could be different but we could still
get these glimpses homages or just
justifications now for a quick summary
before I bring you down memory lane
underneath my magnifying glass blade was
born in 1967 and my mom was born in 1968
so they could have been dating either
way when his mother was bitten by a
vampire she went into premature labor
and died giving birth to him later in
life it's really feel that that baby
blade is now the human vampire hybrid
vampire Hunter he storms a vampiric rave
where blood rings from sprinklers kicks
everyone's ass and sets a vampire known
as quit on fire he escapes when the
police arrive and the hospital Quinn the
burnt vampire awakens and kills Dr
Curtis Webb and devours Karen Jensen's
neck he escapes and blade arrives saving
Karen and taking her to a safe house
where we meet his friend Whistler we
move on to the Council of vampires a
group of pure blood Elder vampires and
frost who leads the younger vampires and
owns the Rave club that we saw earlier
Frost wants to wage war on the humans
and take over the world for vampires
though no one cares what he has to say
because he's not a natural-born vampire
basically calling him inferior also the
vampires don't want to wage a war on the
humans they've been doing great right
now once blade finds pages from The
Vampire valuable he then goes to Pearl
and threw torture by UV light finds out
Frost wants to do a ritual using 12 pure
blood vampires to awaken the blood God
AKA lamagra and Blades blood is the key
a bit later Karen creates a serum that
explodes when combined with vampire
blood Kieran also synthesizes a vaccine
to cure the infected but it won't work
on blade a little earlier Frost kills
one of the Elders of the vampire Council
and breaks into Blaze Hideout killing
Whistler and abducting Karen when blade
shows up it's revealed his mom is still
alive and taken by Frost who was the one
that bit her then all hell breaks loose
blade kills his mom La magra is free but
with a bite to Karen's neck and it's a
very sensual scene blade is back and
defeats Frost goons Frost AKA lamagra
and pledges to continuous Crusade
against the vampires so blades 1998 is a
lot I said his movie's Origins at the
top but in the comics Eric Brooks AKA
blade was born in SoHo London in 1929.
his father Lucas cross was framed and
taken as a prisoner to lot varia his
mother Vanessa then died during birth as
an orphan he was raised in a brothel the
leader is founded by Jamal lafari the
Vampire Hunter and he trained and
mentored Brooks he taught him to fight
hunt and kill vampires and after that
blade had run-ins with everyone Mephisto
Dracula saracen fighting alongside Ghost
Rider Dr Strange truly a ton of folks
and Marvel team up number seven he was
attacked by morbius and turned into a
daywalker his stories are endless and
very fun you really can't have
underworld demon spooky stuff without
looping in Blade to the story at the top
of the movie We're introduced to one of
Deacon's minions Peter Quinn AKA Quinn
for short now blade takes place in Earth
26320 I need to find an easier way to
say that but in the comics there is a
Peter Quinn from earth616 and he was a
mutant known as peepers he was
introduced in 1977's Captain America
annual number four and was recruited by
Magneto to join the Brotherhood of evil
he's been on a ton of different teams
after Magneto dropped him and his powers
are X-ray vision telescopic vision and
optic blast are Quinn and blade has the
same name but clearly no likeness and
seeing as he dies in the end I don't
think he'll be making a big return
though Peter Quinn the mutant did have
ties with Mandrill who we suspect was in
the Intelligentsia and She-Hulk and I
wouldn't be surprised to see him mention
as a member of the toxic team as well
but ultimately his return might seem
pretty low as well one of the most fun
things about Marvel is how easy it is to
make it feel like you're the one
punching the bad guys and saving the
world and now Marvel's got a mobile game
that lets you just do that Marvel snap
is a fast-paced card battler that was
created as a love letter to Marvel fans
like me by Ben broad the designer of
hearthstone and you guys Hearthstone is
one of my favorite games so you know
this is going to be good it's got marble
cred and card battling cred marble snap
pits two players head to head in a fast
six turn game where players fight for
Cosmic cubes trying to overpower their
opponents at two of three locations
manage your energy wisely build your
deck of Heroes carefully then battle and
Bluff your way to Victory look at this
venom look at this Venom best of all
there's no pay to win nonsense in Marvel
snap you have to play to earn cards and
all that upgrades are cosmetic so bling
out your deck if you want to but if you
want to win you're gonna have to
strategize Marvel snap just launched
globally on Steam and mobile Steam and
mobile I know you got one of the two
your account is a cross-platform so any
progress you make on your PC will show
up on your phone and vice versa click
the link in the description below to
download Marvel snap and start playing
it right now because you're gonna love
it the vampire raid has blood spreading
out of the sprinklers which yes
completely gross and I don't think a
single drop landed in any one of these
vampire's mouths they kind of just
rolled in it and rubbed it on their body
anytime they're taking in blood in this
movie they're just licking it they're
not even like eating it uh whatever this
scene though with the sprinklers raining
down blood is now featured in actually
the 2021 Blade the death of Doctor
Strange issue number one also can we
please get a little commotion for the
aesthetic overall the CGI and Vibe
scream scanners and Matrix the MCU
should be so happy that this put them
back on the map because this movie is so
fun it's Peak 90s we're introduced to Dr
Karen Jensen played by nabuche Wright
Jensen is a hematologist hematology is
the study of blood and blood disorder
something I can't live with the MCU has
a ton of women in stem and this one
should not be forgotten Jensen only made
an appearance in the first blade movie
but seemingly created the cure for
vampirism and then the second film they
used it to cure Whistler now this
character could make an appearance in
the new film because the possibilities
are endless if she does if we bring back
her concoction in the hands of good or
bad people could be a treatment or a
curse this could possibly tie up loose
ends or play for the good Stakes game to
come back the chances of them mentioning
this cure or even Dr Karen Jensen I feel
would be really high and because this
movie seemingly uses pretty vague names
of course there is a Dr Jensen in Marvel
Comics Dr Jensen that worked for Hydra
and then there's a Dr Jensen in Earth
21923 but they were named after our Dr
Jensen were later introduced to the
vampire counselor the shadowy council
which is nothing like this vampire
Council which features our boy Wesley
Snipes I mean blade so Canon I doubt it
I mean unless maybe tiger watt features
blade in something uh you know what I
forget by the way the vampires are
grouped into clans of houses one house
is the house of aribus named after the
Greek god of darkness and clearly they
take that book of aribus to heart we
later see the vampire Bible which
contains all their history there was a
prophecy in the Bible that if you use
the blood of 12 pure blood vampires in
one day Walker it would awaken lamagra
that one day Walker was so when they got
it the silver and all that stuff that
they can do in sunlight would also
affect La magra the plan by Deacon is
ultimately free LA magra and turned the
population into vampires in the movie
Lamar created the first vampire AKA
Drake AKA Dracula normally Lamar is
Immortal and Invincible but because
Mercury ruined the ritual by killing a
pure blood at the end it was never
complete therefore it was easier to kill
Deegan once he became him also this God
doesn't exist in mythology the members
of the House of arribus are very hard to
pronounce and I'm so sorry and I'm not
going to try butchering their names this
movie came out in the 1990s I'm sorry
here's a list of them let's just do it
like this let's do it around my head
each of these members have a different
tribe and they have a different glyph
reflecting that tribe though Frost uses
their own glyph they don't really have a
house also worth noting none of these
members are in the comics but whom they
work for and intend to release kind of
connects to those in the comics we'll
get into that shortly and how this clan
could be important to the MCU going
forward just as a reminder there's a
hierarchy to these vampires there's pure
Bloods and turned Bloods which is what
it sounds like purebloods were born as
vampires or the higher ups turn Bloods
where humans turned into vampires and
they're known as inferior then there's
familiars humans willing to serve
vampires like the cop we saw in the
movie day Walkers are AKA blade Revenant
which we see in Dr Curtis Webb later and
Reapers who are like enhanced vampires
that are much more dangerous Frost
Deacon is a turn blood which is why they
treat him as an inferior though he has
so many followers the pure Blitz don't
give two shits about him in this movie
the antagonist is Deacon Frost who
doesn't share likeness to the comic book
character but still exists in Marvel
Comics the OG Frost was one of Blade's
biggest enemies he walked around looking
like an old German man in 1860s Germany
period style clothing but his
doppelganger was made up like a preacher
he was a scientist who accidentally
injected himself with vampire blood and
turned himself into a vampire when
Vanessa Brooks Blade's mom arrived at
the hospital experiencing labor
complications the doctor Frost feasted
on her while she was giving birth to
Blade giving him the half human half
vampire powers so it's not too far off
from the original movie but the
character Frost could make a larger
return Deacon Frost of Earth 616 is a
complete Menace and a boss not only does
he have regenerative Powers superhuman
acute senses can manipulate the weather
he can bite you and it automatically
gives you the powers to generate a
doppelganger and he could make more just
biting the doppelgangers and they would
be under his mind control no one wants
to go up against that that's a true
villain and an annoying one is that I
can't feel like Deacon Frost would be so
cool to see again because no matter
where blade goes the blade anime the one
shot comic the Marvel Ultimate this dude
is always harassing blade his appearance
on Earth 616 I can see making a huge
comeback we're also introduced to
Abraham Whistler Blade's Mentor whose
family was killed by a vampire so he
sworn Revenge ever since Whistler has
been blades Mentor since he was a boy
and helps makes his weapons though in
the comics he was originally mentored by
jazz musician Jamal lafari now there is
an animated version of Abraham Whistler
before Whistler made it into the blade
movie Marvel decided to use him in a
Spider-Man cartoon because they liked
him so much but it stirred up a bunch of
legal disputes because screenwriter
David S goyer created that character and
Marvel didn't own it yet new line did
genuinely I don't think we'd see this
version of Whistler because we'd
probably want to see blade work with a
new mentor and we could explore his
comic origin or create a new one blade
wasn't only trained by Jamal afari he
was also trained by stick who you
probably remember as the man who also
trained Daredevil so we've already got
some training origin story that we can
get into that crosses over the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as a whole
we also learned in this movie that
vampires have weaknesses like most
vampires do crosses don't do squat
vampires are severely allergic to Silver
they'll go into anaphylactic shock when
fed garlic of course uh the good old
sunlight UV rays still work and so do
steaks some of the items that Abraham
makes for blade are the vampire mace the
silver nitrate essence of garlic the
Benelli M3 I don't know guns I'll be
honest uh go figure so I might pronounce
these all wrong the matteli M3 super 90
shotgun modified to shoot silver Stakes
along with his Mac-11 that's shooting
hollowed Point silver bullets filled
with garlic it's so fun that they just
made like this the most cartoony kind of
like how to kill a vampire but it was
said in an interview that the director
and writer was like we didn't want to
make it like a corny corny and use like
crosses because what if a Jewish vampire
showed up and I I appreciate that I
respect that in the script then deleted
they speak on Blade's sword was actually
originally whistlers and was handed down
from Vampire Hunter to vampire Hunter it
was also revealed the original wielder
killed lamagra this was in the first
script and they took it out later on so
maybe they're gonna try bringing it back
what we see here is once Frost is able
to translate and decipher the archives
it's a blueprint to release La magra
clearly it mirrors the ending of the
movie where we see all the pure blood
standing in a circle around Deacon and
blade in his wrist cutting chamber above
also look at these Graphics I love this
90s stuff we're introduced to the Record
Keeper AKA Pearl now Pearl was made for
the movie and their Origins are
basically unknown but in the recent
comic books darkhold blade number one
blade was meant to stop the elder god
and when reading the dark hold it made
him see a Universe where Frost became
lamagra and everyone turned into
vampires and Kingpin became the vampire
King of New York City and when he had an
unquenchable thirst for blood it made
him gluttonous and turned him in to
Pearl what we see here would we see a
Pearl Wilson Fisk I don't think so but
so fun to add maybe if we get a glimpse
of a different universe and we see it I
like that additionally there is a quick
quick series for blade called House of
chathon which we know created the
charcoal now the series doesn't get tied
to the MCU nearly as much as the movies
do but the idea that the other houses
represent or follow different gods and
one of those Gods is chathon is a big
deal that opens the door for those
followers to maybe reach the once Wonder
Gore Mountain and be like what happened
here since Multiverse and Madness or a
bunch of spooky characters meeting up in
the name of their lord and savior so
many possibilities and this is one I can
see heading into a newer blade movie
we're also introduced to ebony Adams the
little girl martial artist that kicks
Blade's ass for like two seconds she was
traveling for a martial arts competition
at the time they found her so I I just
but I I like I like little kids that are
actual badasses that was my favorite
part of Thor love and thunder so I would
love to see this person make a cameo
back in the new blade movie the female
vampire we later sees Mercury one of
Deacon's henchmen who dies by Karen's
hand at the end of the movie having the
mace shot into her mouth and her head
exploded she's not mentioned much in the
comics but she does mess up this ritual
so let's like remember her once the
ritual begins we see the glyphs light up
in electricity soar into the heads of of
purebloods winged bat-like skeletons
unhinged the vampire's Jaws exploding
out of their mouths and doesn't this
kind of look like the Multiverse of
Madness The Souls of the damn it should
in the comics we had a similar ritual
that needed blade instead of Deacon but
ended up going into Deacon anyway it was
named varnay who served for the cult of
the dark holders and was made into a
vampire by the darkhold now do I think
these demon winged skeletons Are the
souls of the Damned yes they're demons
that inhabit the dark hold and though we
don't know much about lamargro they
could have also too you know inhabited
the dark hole demons vampires monsters
will overlap over time in the MCU so
it's not too far off to assume these
creatures live around the same spells so
la magra varnay even saris and Hussan
She-Hulk there was a fly that went near
my face Mephisto either way those
vampires should be crossing paths soon
Deacon when yelling at Karen begins
explaining that blood God is a hurricane
an act of God which is actually pretty
funny because there was an alternate
ending for this movie when Deacon
becomes the magra it was supposed to be
a tornado of blood instead of manifested
into Deacon so this could have been shot
before they followed through with that
then maybe just got that line thought it
was still good and then shot the blood
tornado hurricane and was like ah never
mind and it was it's very silly look at
it because Mercury sucks Deacon lamagra
is defeated by blade and we're served
the best line to ever be served in
cinematics
are always trying to ice skate a bill
that's just some of the things I've
spotted and theorized blade is truly a
great movie and really worth the rewatch
because there's a lot of things that can
be taken from this movie into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe again and even go
into bigger pictures we can just get
into it more and I know they can do it
and I can't wait to see it come out in
2024 just go re-watch it follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at Lulu underscore
Clemons follow new Rockstar subscribe to
new rockstars and hit that notification
Bell thanks for watching Remember
[ __ ] always trying to ice skate
uphill yeah
[Music]